during my
telomere phase as you'll recall there
was
a a discovery that gave me
particular joy associated with the fact
that
dermatologists were talking themselves
silly about the following
observation the expectation was
that exposure to uv causes cancer every
everybody who was dermatologically aware
knew that but it was becoming clear that
people that have very sun damaged skin
farm workers cowboys people who work
under the hot sun
enough that their skin is visibly sun
damaged have very low rates of cancer
right and so it happens that my telomere
work
gives us exactly the reason for this and
it tells you where to draw the line
so first of all sun damaged skin is
damaged
right um it loses its elasticity it
doesn't do
the jobs that skin does that's a healthy
young skin does
as well as it doesn't do it as well as
healthy young skin
but if you are exposed to the sun
continuously and it is damaging tissue
such that you are basically
turning over your cells at a high rate
but you are not getting so much
intensity that it is causing genetic
damage which causes
which is mutations which cause tumors
and what you are doing is effectively
aging your skin
artificially quickly but if you're aging
it without
mutating it then the point is that is
expending
your lifetime capacity for repair and
your lifetime capacity for repair
is what gives you the danger of tumors
because
the capacity of one cell to reproduce
itself many times
after it's had a mutation gives you a
big patch of cells that can get a second
mutation that will turn it into a tumor
but people whose skin is artificially
old because they've spent a lot of time
in the hot sun without getting sunburns
they are they when they get a mutation
it creates a much smaller patch of cells
and so they are actually protected by
the damage so
so once your skin is no longer capable
of repair
you won't ever have youthful looking
skin again but you are also very
unlikely to get cancer in that skin
if you didn't get uh sunburns along the
way
that's that's that's the key thing and
so this also explains the other
interesting phenomenon which was
long known which was that sun burns are
the thing that leads to cancer but it's
early sunburns that lead to cancer later
in your life
so the early sun burns you get a
mutation in a cell from uv
light that cell then starts reproducing
in an unregulated way it becomes a patch
of cells which is a mole basically
and then it stops at its telomeric limit
well the bigger the patch of cells is
when it reaches that limit the greater
the chance that one of those cells will
get a second mutation
that frees it from the limit and turns
it into a tumor so
anyway the the bottom line here at some
level is
biology is always a complex system and
the answers aren't necessarily what you
expect
and you know turns out sunscreen which
we were told that we
you know shouldn't dare go outside
without it uh during the summer it has
many negative effects
that going out in the sun has many
positive effects that those effects are
not necessarily ones you'd predict like
the vitamin d
protective effect against kovid so let's
um
let's actually just talk a little bit
more about um
what what we have done and what we did
with our with our kids early on when
all of the advice and every time we'd
send them to school or camp or something
we were told you know you have to pack a
tube with sunscreen and probably come
back empty and all of this and we
we didn't do this um so i'd i'd like to
share just a little bit
about you know how and how and why um
but also
say that um you know your point
that early sunburn predicts later cancer
uh does raise the issue of okay what is
the boundary between a burn and a tan
and yotan is this protective response by
the skin
but of course almost everyone has had
the
experience of you know spending a little
bit too much time outside thinking you
got away with it thinking it went to tan
and then finding that it was actually a
burn underneath and so
this like basically boundaries between
categories and every complex system that
you can name
is fuzzy right and so you know you want
to avoid getting too near that
that border between tan and burn as well
well i agree the problem is it's fuzzy
in
the moment in other words you will have
a burn before you have any evidence that
you have a burn
on the other hand my experience is
analog but the actual like did it mutate
or did it not is digital
well it's not even did it mutate because
you may not end up with a mutation
did you damage tissue such that it
requires replacement so that you end up
with the sloughing of skin that comes
with the burn
uh the alternative being your skin
anticipates
damage based on detecting a lot of
sunlight and it darkens
if you're light skinned it darkens the
color of your skin in order to protect
the cells
that are there and so the tan the sweet
spot is
where you got enough sun to trigger this
but you didn't get so much sun that you
damaged tissue and then
genetic damage is one layer beyond that
and that's the thing that you have to
worry about now here's an interesting
phenomenon so i used to burn
very very easily and i did get some of
those sunburns
in youth that tend to predispose a
person to skin cancer
but i've also learned just by observing
my own interaction
with the world how to manage it without
sunscreen
right so that hat on my twitter profile
is
part of my strategy when i'm in the
field especially in the tropics
is that how it's great it's also great
for rain um
keeps the rain off of off of your face
which is really
very useful but that's a great
conversation starter uh it's a terrible
conversation starter people assume it's
some sort of a
prop right um but anyway the the thing
that i learned about myself
which i've now taught my kids and when
they think of it it works for them too
is that you can get a lot of sun
exposure where you're headed towards a
burn
and then you can take a short break like
a five minute break in the shade or if
you there's no shade you can turn so a
different side of you is facing the sun
and it seems to reset some sort of
counter and
the thing that i think is interesting is
it suggests an
a process that is analogous to what we
now know about covet infection
so covet infection at least as our
current model looks
there's like a bucket and that bucket as
long as it doesn't reach the top
means that even if you encountered some
covid you're very unlikely to get sick
it's only when the bucket overflows
because you've had
exposure over some period of time and
the bucket filled up
that you're likely to get it which means
if you're outside which is
constantly emptying the bucket you're
very low risk
so viral particles fly away from you
right and so there's something and
uh i'd be hard-pressed to tell you what
it is i don't know but there's something
about these
the mechanism with respect to the sun
damage
there's something about the skin that is
able to tolerate a certain amount of
sun intensity and if you just keep
building it up
you it's like it's like a bucket that
has a hose in it
that's bigger you know that's putting in
more water than the leak in the other
side of the bucket the bucket eventually
overflows
but if you allow it to drain and
draining in the case of the sun exposure
it's just a matter of giving it some
time in which you're not bombarding it
with new
sunlight seems to reset something and so
the thing that's surprising to me is
that it's not it's not like
you catch an hour in the sun you need a
half an hour in the shade it's half an
hour in the sun
you need two or three minutes in the
shade nor can you just count
up the number of minutes you want to
spend in the sun and say okay i'm just
going to take that all at once
you know say say you have skin that can
tolerate three hours
um that you have calculated can tolerate
three hours in the sun at a time well
that's that's
youthful and extraordinarily sun
resilient skin
but actually say you did it for three
hours you could probably take a break
and at three hours you didn't maybe 15
20 minutes
and go back out again yeah now this this
really does seem to be
the experience i have i have less direct
empirical experience just because i
don't
i don't tend to burn but we've seen it
with you and both of our children
as well yeah the other the last thing i
would say and first of all this is just
my experience
you know it's not uh it's anecdote at
best
um so your mileage is almost certainly
going to vary and you have to
figure out your own pattern um but i
sometimes find that when i blow it a
little bit and i go too far
and i know this because when i come in
finally you know my skin is hot
it's like i did is that a burn you can
go a certain amount too far
and then it doesn't end up being a burn
so there's some sort of
uh you have exceeded tolerances but not
so much
that it's gone critical phase which
allows you to actually know where you
are in finding that border
but it requires that you pay attention
to the feedback your body is giving you
right it requires that you have a sense
of what your skin
and your breathing and everything else
about your physiology normally feels
like so that as
it begins to send you warning signals
excuse me
you are in a position to read them and
to receive them yeah
absolutely and a lot of things work this
way medically speaking we're paying
attention to the patterns even if you
don't know what the underlying mechanism
is you can manage things